Elizabeth is with us in Fort Wayne
Indiana she's in one of our foundations
in personal finance high school classes
there at Columbia City High School hi
Elizabeth how are you hi I'm good how
about you better than I deserve
how can I help you today I'm calling to
my personal finance class remember and
what happens to that if you pass away
with no relatives or heirs to take
responsibility for it it does not get
paid and the heirs are not responsible
for it even if there are errors so let's
say that your mom and dad died and they
were a hundred thousand dollars in debt
and they did not own anything you as
their heir do not inherit debt you don't
take up the debt even if there is an
error the only time the only thing that
the only way the debt gets paid is if
they own enough stuff to pay the debt so
let's say your mom and dad passed away
and they owed $100,000 but they owned a
$200,000 paid for house well that house
would have to be sold to pay those debts
and you would only get the difference
but you cannot be held responsible
personally for the debt there a state is
the only thing that stands good for
their debt upon them dying so that's why
it's so stupid for these banks to give
an 85 year old a credit card does that
make sense yeah so you see the
difference though yes okay so they're
what they own stands good for what they
owe
but the heirs don't and and even if
there aren't any if there aren't any
heirs are there are any heirs the bank
just simply does not get paid so
sometimes when I'm on the air here I
talked to someone who's you know dad
passed away he was 80 years old he lived
in an apartment renting didn't own
anything and had $40,000 for the credit
card debt that $40,000 worth a credit
card that simply does not get paid that
Bank lost that money because honestly
because they loaned it to somebody they
shouldn't have hello I mean because that
he didn't have any assets and and in you
know when he dies they don't get paid
and so they were
stupid for loaning him that money but
that's the business risk that that Bank
took by loaning him that money they're
the ones that lose the money not you and
me it doesn't cost you and me anything
it didn't cost the public anything it
costs the company that is owed the money
they're the ones that lose the money the
bank okay okay thank you
I'll tell mr. Ambrose thanks for
teaching your class okay yep very cool
stuff all right thanks for calling in